el pulpo o dignado a casa con una
velocidad constante marca una distancia
que recorría cada séptimo de segundo en
la gráfica de abajo no todos los pulpos
pueden crear gráficas pero bueno o dino
es un pulpo común cuál es la velocidad
de audi en metros por segundo es
importante que hagamos la observación
que usamos metros por segundo para
mostrar las unidades de metros por
segundo que lo representamos como metros
sobre segundo y lo que aquí nos están
pidiendo es la velocidad de od y
nosotros vamos a calcular la velocidad
como la distancia que odia está
recorriendo distancia en metros por la
cantidad de tiempo
que mediremos en segundos
con eso tenemos metros sobre segundo ven
es esta medida que hemos utilizado aquí
entonces vamos a tomar un punto que esté
perfectamente marcado y de estos puntos
que fue graficando y podemos hablar de
este punto
el cual está perfectamente ubicado y
podemos ver que en distancia recorrió
4 séptimos vamos a escribirlos aquí 4
séptimos de metro ha recorrido en qué
tiempo vamos a checar dónde está el
tiempo el tiempo no nos está indicando
aquí
el tiempo son cinco séptimos
y esto lo tenemos en segundos estamos de
acuerdo
ok una vez que tenemos esto podemos
pensar entonces que vamos a hacer la
división de 4 séptimos entre cinco
séptimos vamos a reescribir lo
para que nos quede muy claro 4 séptimos
será dividido entre 5
y aquí tenemos los metros sobre segundos
como lo habíamos manejado anteriormente
vamos a ponerlos ahora como metros sobre
segundo
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es esta
división y para que nosotros podemos
hacer una división de fracciones lo que
haremos es multiplicar
los cuatro séptimos que tenemos y la
división la llevaremos a cabo por la
multiplicación de su recíproco es decir
cuatro séptimos lo multiplicaremos
siete quintos de hecho podemos ver aquí
cómo se cancelan los sietes ya que uno
está como numerador y otro como
denominador y tendremos entonces cuatro
quintos 4
o de hecho podemos irnos aquí arriba a
nuestra operación original y si cada uno
de estos los multiplicamos por 7
se eliminaría este 7 con este 7 este con
éste y de cualquier manera tendríamos
cuatro quintos y esa será nuestra
respuesta correcta hemos de colocar
son cuatro metros sobre
5 segundos es decir esta es la velocidad
que audi estaba utilizando cuatro
quintos metros por segundo